Kevin, when your wife was here a couple weeks ago
we asked her a few questions
about you and your relationship.
And if it's okay, we want to ask you some
of those same questions and just see
if any of the answers match up.
Okay. I'll give it a shot.
All right, Kevin Bacon.
This is your wife!
(upbeat music)
♪ "Here Comes the Bride" ♪
(audience clapping)
So, what fun is a game, you know, without a little stake?
So Kyra says that she's gonna tell you
what you are playing for.
Let's take a look.
Okay.
So, Kev, if you get four out of five right,
I will clean the dinner dishes for the next year,
but, if you get them wrong
you have to clean the dinner dishes for the next year.
(Drew laughs)
(audience laughs)
Wow. That's... a year?
Wow. Okay.
Okay. Are you ready?
I'm ready.
Your family has matching tattoos.
If you got a tattoo right now, what would it be?
Princess Kikanoke.
Here's what Kyra said.
If Kevin got a tattoo right now
I think it might say "six degrees" for his sixdegrees.org.
Not for the reason everybody will think it will be,
but for the sixdegrees.org.
(fail buzzer sound)
Oh well.
Uh oh.
(audience laughs)
Look, I'm gonna be doing some dishes.
Okay.
What is something of yours
that Kyra would just love for you to get rid of?
Something I would love to get rid of?
Maybe an old pair of sneakers.
Eurgh. Here's what she said.
The thing I would like Kevin to get rid of
is some of his t-shirts.
I'm a big fan of him in collared shirts.
(fail buzzer sound)
Yeah. She made me put on a collared shirt today. Yeah.
Cute. Okay. What's one thing of Kyra's
that you would love to throw out?
Oh, I would say all of her earrings.
I have an earring phobia.
I really don't like earrings.
Well, here's what Kyra said.
I know I'm gonna be right about this one.
The things of mine that Kevin would like me to get rid of
are all my earrings.
Not a fan of earrings.
(audience claps and cheers)
Okay. If you could eat one meal
for the rest of your life, what would it be?
Pizza.
Uh huh. Okay.
Here's what Kyra said.
If Kevin had to eat one meal for the rest of his life
I think it would be something like a fish taco.
(fail buzzer sound)
(Drew laughs)
(audience laughs)
You know... she's actually right.
She knows you better than you know yourself, right?
She knows me better than I know myself.
Okay. Last question.
Which goat is your favorite goat?
Well, I hate to play favorites
but Macon is... Macon Bacon is pretty irresistible.
Here's what she said.
Kevin's favorite goat is Macon.
Shh! Don't tell Louis.
(Kevin laughs)
(audience laughs)
(high pitched bell rings)
We might be getting dirty with those dishes later.
And I thank you so much, Kevin Bacon,
for coming on the show today.
Really. Thank you.
(audience claps)
Thanks for having me, Drew
I'm a big fan and it's fantastic what you're doing
and keep up the great work.
Well, thank you.
City on a Hill airs Sundays on Showtime
at 9:00 pm Eastern and Pacific.
Say hi to Kyra for me.
Will do.
(upbeat outro music)